we are in Savannah Georgia and we are
working on The Exorcist
we pick up the story of Victor and his
daughter Angela we'd be home by dinner I
love you good morning Mr Fielding Angela
and Catherine have been friends we and
Catherine doing out there in those woods
you're just walking and walking
Victor's put church and Faith behind him
Todd and exposes Victor to other ways to
look at the world it's about different
people of different beliefs and
religions coming together wherever those
girls went they brought something back
with him
you think they've got possessed by the
devil
rally around a story really that's about
the power of love going to face of
spiritual obstacles emotional Ops all
those things exorcism is a ritual every
culture every religion they all use
different methods it's when they take
all of them you would look to ancestors
you would look to Spirits for guidance
out of sometimes deep despair the
ability to build something that is
life-affirming life-giving and pass it
down if you don't make it I don't make
it in this moment it is about the love
of a father and a daughter to see
ourselves in this scenario is a huge
thing it's going to open the story up
it's a way to bring it into the present
and that's why representation is so
important one girl lives one girl dies
spirituality is a part of everything we
do whether you believe or not believe
there's something bigger than us the
truth in humanity and Desperation those
relatable emotions God
they trick on you